boy wasn't that a zany experience hey
guys how's it going welcome back to
table tug this is the only other game
that would be played with able to put a
little John hey guys how's it going
welcome back to table tug hope you
enjoyed that little titty that we did
little ditty and we did I don't know
what a titty is but we are you don't
know a 2d with the DS now forget the I D
dy no table duck huh Tuggle table table
Doug scratch that out put tongue table
tug because [ __ ] up the [ __ ] the
fumble
we've devolved into madness it's it's
lit very late we've had a long weekend
we've been trying to do as much as
possible but also we've been going to
see improv shows we just got back from
one and we got so tired from laughing
that we're kind of loopy but it's time
to learn I pictured a but this city
really their money you pictured a but
that's the that's the level that your
brings my brain is their brain is
changes like summer race humor face
humor there's no such thing as base
humor with you it's just sub-basement
selves of a dead as the man said titty I
didn't mean to say I didn't go titty
haha but I'm stats my joke
I said kitty is every time you tell them
but um that's my joke but I'm that's my
joke I don't want to do this could you
spit everywhere we do them no please
it's like my threat every time I want to
win I just I know i fried whoa whoa whoa
I'm totally whoa whoa you just started
at the you went crazy now you're gonna
ask if he's and we're back I kind of
forgotten how to play no like you're
supposed to like no no you
it's like it's there's a physics to it
that you're supposed to like get that
bridge and the angle over baby
and the know we're big hallway okay well
let the same thing well I be like
there's like a lover to you what do you
do is you keep leaping at the beginning
okay because I used to be good at this
yeah you were I was never nice except
for like one time you like completely
destroyed me and and see you're like no
no no
haha titties kids aren't allowed no man
this is embarrassing yes it is
but I shouldn't brag me as I know as
soon as I start breaking breaking
breaking breaking it's gonna end we were
I don't know what you deranged my goats
up at the beginning you win if I jump at
the beginning you win are fine I'm gonna
do a blindfolded next I'm gonna now I
don't want to see you blind remember I'm
gonna cover my eyes all right we're
gonna play this game you ready yeah okay
no oh my goodness what you peaked on you
no I did that I'm Pete I'm gonna do all
of these completely blindfolded wait am
I on the right button no there we go ah
[ __ ] I threw the black folding that's
what you're doing in one round no good
I'd like my black shitty blindfolding
yeah the gray it is whatever Oh
shower me and titties no I will not
you won't do that for me waiting on be
on camera okay okay okay
no no no I we
oh did I win where's the WMI on the deck
there oh [ __ ] what's the W is that it
was good it was that the double yeah
you're on the W yeah I know my oh yeah
well they are Danny where's the W here
yes okay [ __ ]
so we're going oh god dammit what
happened what happens in one what yeah
you won the whole thing
oh yeah gorgeous four out of five of
those I couldn't even see it I just
watch that stupid quiz five all the
beans beans to yunho's game well I'm
giving you a chance here have you win it
I will I will lose graciously all right
all the beans all the beans see now that
I'm actually gonna be paying as one
everybody Wow all the bearings all the
beads is still possible long legs it
changes things right
come on No please be good your orange
legs are longer than I am good
III am trying to be good any oh come on
come on blue
you're my book lad oh you're my boy blue
my bed your head blew off oh this more
like I blew my one chance of crisis oh
my god hahahahahaha pelvic thrust into
victory what what hey are you surprised
I want to go back to mold hammer we can
do mole hammers
we give you mole hammers in this video
oh yeah I don't know why guys one well
that's how I am with mole oh say titty
titty say it loud and proud and into the
mic
titty Lauda drought that is so stupid
why wait why am I doing this I don't
know I want the sound bite to use
against you later let's play mole
hammers 20 seconds
oh God well okay that's a little better
than hey hey guys welcome to mole
hammers there's what he seconds of oh
hello live-action intro to this here we
go [ __ ] oh yes tell [ __ ] oh god I just
stopped you from getting it it'll be
admitted oh that was what I lost the aim
of a stupid rabbit oh that's what you
get titty man that's because if I turn
him yes City man episode oh man oh no
whoa jeez
oh you can't just spam oh you got that
ah [ __ ] have it I'm gonna win I know
oh come on I'm gonna get that war I was
like no not one yeah that one yeah he
hit him twice anyway cuz he had a helmet
I know but I could have held into them
twice so I won twice in a row it's not
my night it's not it's not your night
you know that was preempted by a melon
oh geez
ah these twenty second matches are
bullcrap they're complete white crap
why'd they go for 90 seconds to 22nd
where it's almost too long to where you
can't do it why not do 45 seconds I love
it done perfect okay all right guys
we're done I'm done trying to do this
outro right because I can't but it's
been a long night we love you very much
we really do we have a delightful time
playing these games it was good having
you in LA sorry you got to leave so soon
sorry had to do so much of that other
crap that you had to do that was
probably important thanks again
everybody so much for watching check out
wigs Channel Lord million seven seven
seven and as always we'll see you in the
next video bye bye
fast-fast